Now, you see we have a parseJSON function that takes a string of JSON in, and
then we're going to parse it using the JSON.parse method that is included in and
accessible in just about any modern browser. JSON.parse takes this string,
Weapon.JSON in and will return a JavaScript object representing the JSON that it's
parsed. Now, once we've done that what I want you to do is grab a specific piece
of data, from that JSON. Let's say you want to grab data from the JavaScript
object returned from JSON.parse and let's say you put that JavaScript object
into the variable "parsed". Now in order to grab the chaingun sub object then
you'd simply say parsed frames chaingun.png like so and then put it in the
variable chaingun let's say. Now let's take a look up above at this structure.
What I would do, it'd walk down first on frames and then in the chaingun
and what would be stored in the chaingun variable, would then be this entire
structure, so everything inside of chaingun.png. Now what I would like you to
do, is grab the x data field inside spriteSourceSize of chaingun_impact.png
and go ahead and print that out to the console. chaingun_impact.png isn't up in
our example JSON, but the JSON that we'll be running through this function
does have it.